bonjour à tous alors d'abord une petite
réflexion par rapport à votre
intervention monsieur Tarzan parce que
vous avez parlé de l'aéroport
Cayenne Félix Éboué ou parliez de hub
effectivement vous avez bien raison et
je pense que le ministre de transport
ferait bien de se pencher justement sur
cette orientation mais par contre mon
intervention va plus sur la continuité
territoriale à l'intérieur du territoire
parce que la Guyane vous la connaissez
nos compatriotes de l'Intérieur ne
peuvent pas se déplacer comme ils
veulent d'ailleurs j'en veux pour preuve
le le prochain déplacement
de la mission sur la continuité
territoriale qui doit se déplacer à
Marie pasula nous n'avons pas de place
sur le vol puisque je serai présente et
c'est une grosse difficulté pour nous
compatriotes de l'Intérieur sincèrement
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous ai posé la question je sais pas qui
pourra me répondre même si c'est pas
aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que pas réponse
écrite pour vous demander si vous avez
respect à l'intérieur de de votre
territoire puisque nous nos communes de
l'Intérieur ne sont pas reliés par un
réseau routier donc nous sommes ils sont
obligés de prendre ou la pirogue ou
l'avion malheureusement il y a une DSP
effectivement pour Marie pinsula pour
grandir pas pour papa et je tombe
puisqu'il y a pas d'aérodrome et je peux
vous dire c'est plutôt 40 ans moi je
sais que le président de la CTG
développe des efforts pour réhabiliter
l'aérodrome de de Maripasoula mais
n'empêche que c'est au niveau des avions
alors des avions de 18 places alors
imaginez les les
compatriotes de l'Intérieur qui veulent
venir sur Cayenne puisque c'est sur le
littoral qu'on a toutes les réponses aux
problématiques et je peux vous dire
sincèrement c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me fais un plaisir d'être
présente chaque fois qu'il y a la
mission continuité territoriale pourra
alerter parce que vous imaginez on parle
enfin le collègue de sénateur vient de
parler de pour les évasades pour tout ça
imaginez les difficultés que rencontre
nos compatriotes et ça je tiens chaque
fois le souligner parce qu'il faut faire
quelque chose c'est vrai le hub c'est
intéressant c'est vrai c'est porteur
c'est économiquement parlant ce serait
très bien pour la Guyane pour la France
mais il faut aussi penser à nos
compatriotes de l'Intérieur qui souvent
nos étudiants aussi qui font des qui
sont à l'université de Guyane à Cayenne
et lorsqu'il y a des vacances qui sont
incapables de rentrer chez eux dans leur
famille parce que il y a pas de place
sur le vol ou quelquefois il y a pas du
tout de vol d'ailleurs et franchement je
crois qu'il est temps nous sommes 21e
siècle il est temps que nous puissions
résoudre cette problématique voilà ce
que je voulais partager avec vous mais
en tout cas monsieur Targent je suis
très heureuse de vous entendre parler de
hub moi je ne pense qu'à ça pour mon
pays il faut que nous évoluons il faut
que nous nous modernisions et nous
devions surtout optimiser notre position
géographique sur le continent
sud-américain puisqu'en fait de la
Guyane c'est le seul territoire
ultramaret qui n'est pas insulaire voilà
voilà ce que je voulais partager avec
vous merci présidente